Infinity Wards rebooted Modern Warfare 2
brings back a more classic Call of Duty
multiplayer experience than we've seen
in recent years with maps better
tailored to traditional 6v6 play and
dialed back movement mechanics Modern
Warfare 2's gameplay really feels like a
refreshing return to Old Times again but
unfortunately the package as a whole
feels lacking
as a whole Modern Warfare 2's
multiplayer is the fast-paced shooter
you expected to be the standard maps are
scaled down for six V6 matches this year
so there's less quiet and campy moments
and you're almost always finding
yourself in the thick of the action
Modern Warfare 2 does dial back the
overly fast-paced movement of recent
years too but that doesn't mean you
can't choose a run and Gun play style
the gameplay is just a bit less Twitchy
too as the movement feels more on par
with the original Modern Warfare series
than the 2019 version
sliding doesn't quite feel as fast and
fluid as Modern Warfare 2019 and the
bunny hopping movement has been nerved a
little since the beta you can still hop
around a corner but there's not a build
up of an overly aggressive speed that
lets you start hopping all over the map
this makes the multiplayer movement feel
more grounded and slower paced than the
last few entries of the franchise which
is a great change the last few years of
Call of Duty has left the majority of
the Casual player base at a disadvantage
in trying to counter the hopping and
sliding frenzy Modern Warfare 2 launched
with the typical modes perks and
killstreaks but there are a few notable
features missing from this year's game
at launch
another fumble for Infinity Ward is that
Modern Warfare 2 is alienating a huge
chunk of the player base at launch with
the lack of a hardcore playlist which
the developer has renamed as Tier 1 mode
and says will now release on November
16th with the launch of season 1 and
Call of Duty Warzone 2.0 there is an
entire community of hardcore players
that always get to play this mode at
launch who had no idea their preferred
playlist wouldn't be available all of
these missing features and lack of a
hardcore playlist are a bummer because
this is an otherwise refreshing return
to Classic Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2
provides standard maps that are better
designed with the core 6v6 experience in
mind while ground war has battle maps
for the large-scale mode there are a few
standard maps that are also a piece of a
larger ground war map but the standard
version of the map still feels
appropriately sized for core multiplayer
for example Mercado Las Almas is a solid
6v6 map for all game modes but the
location can also be found tucked away
in the last Alma setting in the guiharo
ground war map there are 10 standard
maps and five battle maps standout Maps
include Mercado Los Almas which features
a small marketplace with fast-paced
routes no matter the mode you choose
there's always some action happening on
Mikado another strong map is Crown
Raceway which is a nighttime map set at
a Formula One race track this layout
doesn't quite feature a classic
three-lane map design but it's not
overly complex and the map flows really
well across all game modes of course
almost every Call of Duty has one
unpopular or controversial map and this
year it's Santa Sana border crossing
this has an awkward layout as it's just
a long strip of Highway congested with
cars there are a few small building
things along both sides of the highway
but the map leaves much to be desired in
terms of variety most of the fighting
takes place with nothing but the traffic
jam of cars many of which will explode
from damage it only takes one grenade or
kill streak to set up a chain reaction
of exploding cars which can quickly turn
deadly Modern Warfare 2 features 10 game
modes to choose from in standard
multiplayer this includes the staple
game modes like Team Deathmatch
domination hardpoint Surge and Destroy
and free fall and all of these can
provide a great time in Modern Warfare
2. sadly there are only two new modes
being introduced here called prisoner
rescue and knockout and they leave much
to be desired in terms of objective
gameplay prisoner rescue is a 6v6 mode
that requires players to take turns
either trying to defend or rescue two
prisoners on the map knockout is a very
similar 6v6 round based mode with fast
rounds in the a best of five match where
both teams fight to hold a bag of cash
both prisoner rescue and knockout are no
respawn modes but players can revive
their fallen teammates to get them back
in the match both new 6v6 modes are
underwhelming and it's a shame that both
new modes added this year are so similar
to one another knockout or prisoner
rescue both play out similarly usually
devolving into rounds of Team Deathmatch
with very few teammates ever bothering
to play The Objective which can often
happen in Call of Duty modes unless
there are measures in place to entice
players to play the actual objective
matches can often lead to becoming a
kill Fest that goes to time instead of
score both modes seem to be meant to
introduce a non-re spawn mode that plays
faster than Search and Destroy but both
like any real creativity compared to
some of Call of Duty's past modes such
as Black Ops 4's Counter-Strike leg
heist mode ground wall returns for those
who want a bigger fight than 6v6 again
providing 32 v32 large-scale Warfare
played on sprawling Maps there are two
ground war modes available with the
choice of standard or Invasion mode
standard ground war is much like modern
warfare 2019's successful mode serving
as an oversized domination match with
five control points to capture and hold
for points this standard mode is chaotic
fun with tank battles air support boat
fights and underwater combat This truly
feels like Call of Duty sandbox mode and
there's something for everyone here
ground war has a really strong map pool
with each featuring plenty of building
variety and verticality to cater to all
play Styles and weapon types ground war
Invasion meanwhile is a team deathmatch
style mode with a point system that goes
beyond just getting kills to rack up a
score you're also awarded points for
shooting down enemy kill streaks or
destroying their vehicles unfortunately
this feels like the weaker of the two
modes another major addition is the
ability to play Modern Warfare 2's
standard maps in third person this is a
separate playlist with mixed respawn
modes thankfully third person mode has
one of the most notable changes from the
beta as Infinity Ward has adjusted the
perspective while aiming so you'll only
switch from third person to first person
perspective when aiming down sights with
Scopes over 4X Zoom the change in
perspective does help and I find myself
now able to play and enjoy the mode
without feeling queasy from the constant
swap of perspective this is a much more
in enjoyable experience than the
previous style of constantly switching
between perspectives although Modern
Warfare 2 takes us back to the past with
classic movement and traditional map
design one component Infinity War pushes
further is the gunsmith weapon
customization feature this year's
gunsmith adds a new layer of complexity
for unlocking weapons and crafting the
best build the gunsmith's new platform
system is essentially created to
eliminate the grind of unlocking the
same attachment over and over for
different guns which sounds great in
theory but it actually ends up being a
different type of time consuming
headache unlocking guns and attachments
is no longer a simple process of just
leveling up and using the weapon you
want instead you're forced to use
weapons in other classes just to unlock
attachments and additional weapons
overall it's nice not to need to unlock
the same attachments over and over again
but the complexity of how the entire
platform system is designed could be
overwhelming for new or casual players
I'm not a big fan of snipers or light
machine guns but I'm essentially being
forced to level them up to get some of
the attachments I want for my assault
rifles and submachine guns the game also
adds a shooting range where you can now
go to test out the guns you've spent
time building this is something the
community has been asking for and it's
great to have the option to test out
different attachments to better find
something to suit your play style Modern
Warfare 2's guns also look and sound
great with the reload animations and
gunfire audio up to par with modern
warfare 2019's Stellar quality Modern
Warfare 2 also comes packaged with spec
ops mode which is a two-player Co-op
experience of large-scale missions
taking place in almazara the new map
location for Warzone 2.0 there are three
missions available with more to come
post launch so far my time with these
missions makes the mode feel somewhere
in between the original spec ops
experience in 2009's Modern Warfare 2
and Modern Warfare 2019 these missions
are a little more open world than the
smaller set pieces used in The Fan
Favorite 2009 version but this reboot is
not as buggy nor plagued with the same
overwhelming enemy spawn system that
Modern Warfare 2019 had Modern Warfare
2's version of spec ops also introduces
a new layer to the mode with kits which
is like having a set Loadout of perks
field upgrades and killstreaks tailored
to fit the role you choose for example
the assault kit lets you equip an extra
armor plate and leveling up the kit will
get you additional benefits such as
faster reload stims and additional armor
plates you can also easily get through
all three spec ops missions without
having to utilize these kits at all but
they are beneficial if you're going for
fast completion times hopefully the kits
will be more beneficial for the game's
seasonal content as they don't really
feel worth the grind to level up yet
Activision says the kits will also be
used for Modern Warfare 2's upcoming
raids feature which the publisher
described as a three-player Cooperative
mode with a mix of combat and puzzles
and maybe they'll be better utilized
there
I'm playing Modern Warfare 2 on
PlayStation 5 and the first two days
were rough with frequent freezes and
crashes but an update has dramatically
reduced the number of crashes for me
others have experienced various bugs
spec-up glitches and features like
pinging and the weapon tuning are
currently disabled due to some game
breaking issues taking all of this into
account I'm still having a great time
playing Modern Warfare 2. despite the
rough launch weekend however it just
can't be ignored that the overall
package is missing those core
multiplayer features it's definitely the
gameplay and classic feel that saves the
experience for me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]